- I have been such a fan of this gentleman
for so many years.
Please welcome the host of
"A Late Show with Stephen
Colbert," the Stephen Colbert.
(crowd applauding)
- Drew, hello, how do
you have an audience?
I don't understand, I'm so
jealous that you actually have
people clapping and applauding.
What's going on?
- Well, it's funny that
you should ask, actually.
It's our crew and you
wanna say hi to Stephen?
(crowd applauding)
- Would you like to hear my crew?
(man whooping)
I got two old guys in here.
(Drew laughing)
- Well, I wish you could be
here on this set with us.
- It looks fantastic.
You're bathed in golden light.
I love your background.
I saw a wide shot, while I was
waiting to come on the show,
I saw a wide shot.
I love your background, it's very like
very high Hollywood, TV, 1970s.
It's very Merv, it's
very Johnny, I love it.
- I mean, listen, take a look at this.
I wanted to show you a
little groovy shot over here.
There you go.
- I like it already, that's nice.
- 'Cause six Stephen
Colberts isn't enough.
(crowd laughing)
- Can I ask a question?
- Yah.
- Do you mind if I ask a question?
Are you making papier-mache,
why do you have so many
newspapers in front of you?
You look like the mother of a third-grader
about to make a pinata.
(Drew laughing)
- And it's true, we could.
Because I just figured, I
think it's, in some contexts
I always wonder why is
there nothing on that desk?
Because my desk at home is a complete,
you-know-what show, and it's--
- Ah?
Of all the detritus and things that I--
- I don't actually know what,
Drew, I don't know what.
- See, you have something on your desk.
I mean, most desks are--
- I have a bone.
I have a bone with my name carved in it.
This was a bone that I
found in my brother's yard
when I was a child.
It's a cow bone, I'll have you know.
Before anybody sends forensics.
I have a cup, I have my
phone, and I have this.
What is this?
It's a leather coaster.
(Drew laughing)
That's it.
- I love the way that
you have religion in your show,
because it shows that it's
a part of who you are and
it's in the stained glass.
And the essence of it is all around.
But, like most things,
you don't seem to press it upon people.
- No.
- There is a statement.
You are making a truth, you
are telling without saying,
"This has to be your truth."
Am I correct in that?
- Yeah, sure, sure.
I mean, I don't purposely
include anything in the show.
I just talk about the things
I know and I care about.
And obviously also my writers,
and my staff, and my producers.
But yeah, no, I don't want
anybody to be like me.
I don't always want me to be like me,
so I wouldn't wanna press
that on somebody else.
- Well, that's a good segue, if you will.
- That's what I do, Drew.
- Ah, I love a good segue.
What persona, character
is the most like you
in real life?
Is it Colbert, is it
the man who is hosting
the late night show?
- I guess, no, this is me,
the old guy was kind of like
a confession of my insecurities
and also my sort of,
I don't know, appetites
anybody may have if they just
gave into their ego completely.
If they just gave into every indulgence,
like I have to be the
most important person.
I have to be the thing
that everything's about,
I can never be wrong, you have to love me.
All of those things are
always kind of nagging at,
at least my mind.
That's sort of like, it's
like a confession of weakness,
the old character.
All these indulgences of
selfishness that your psyche
is always asking you to give into.
And the great thing about the old show
is that I could piggyback
on his desires and his ego
and pretend they weren't my own,
but really it was just a mask
you could wear to confess.
And I think people maybe
recognized that in themselves.
And maybe that's why they
didn't consider him a,
I can't use the word on daytime,
but it's not a nice part of your body.
(Drew laughing)
- It's a Chris Evans.
(both laughing)
- Yeah, poor Chris
Evans, poor Chris Evans.
So handsome and fit, I
feel so sorry for him.
(Drew laughing)
- Do you miss that?
And--
- Nope, not at all.
I don't miss that at all.
I like being me, I like being me.
This is so much better.
A, the old show, I didn't have
the greatest band in television,
Jon Batiste and Stay Human.
The old show, I couldn't actually,
sometimes you just gotta come
around, even the little mask
that you wear as the persona
of a host, and come around
and just speak directly to the audience.
Especially when things
are particularly dark.
Like they are right now.
The brightest thing or
the way to fight against
the darkness is to actually
just to speak honestly
about it and try to
make a human connection.
'Cause that's really mostly
what I just wanna do,
is just have some sort
of sense of community
with my audience.
(upbeat music)